you've you've also said that the matrix
may be one of your more favorite AI
related movies can you elaborate why
yeah it is one of my favorite movies and
it's because it represents kind of all
the things I think about so there's a
symbiotic relationship between robots
and humans right that symbiotic
relationship is that they don't destroy
us they enslave us right but think about
it even though they enslaved us they
needed us to be happy right and in order
to be happy they had to create this
Kruti world that they then had to live
in right that's the whole thing
but then there were humans that had a
choice wait like you had a choice to
stay in this horrific horrific world
where it was your fantasy and life with
all of the anomalies perfection but not
accurate or you can choose to be on your
own and like have maybe no food for a
couple of days but you were totally
autonomous and so I think of that as and
that's why so it's not necessarily us
being enslaved but I think about us
having this symbiotic relationship
robots and AI even if they become
sentient they're still part of our
society and they will suffer just as
much as us and there there will be some
kind of equilibrium that we'll have to
find some some symbiotic relationship
and then you have the ethicist the
robotics folks that like no this has got
to stop I will take the other peel yeah
in order to make a difference
you